people love the internet's retro Records
who are here and this deck right here is
essentially the one that carried me all
the way to Diamond I'm gonna be breaking
down each card for you and also showing
you some gameplay of two matches so you
can get a feel for how this deck plays
now to start with we have the echo
probably the most important part of
setting up any deck is the type of echo
you choose to play with Bellatrix
obviously very very strong right now in
1v1 so the way the Bellatrix Echo works
is you're going to have this little
meter under your health bar and when
that meter fills it will spawn a Death
Eater now if you do it twice you get two
Death Eaters if you do it a third time
you get three Death Eaters I don't know
I'm assuming you could probably get four
as well I've never seen it go on that
long but I have seen it get to three and
it can get pretty crazy so because of
the fact that I'm using the Bellatrix
echo my focus is on damage I want to get
as many hits as possible in very rapid
succession so bomb box is an absolute
must I mean bomb box is so strong right
now this is gonna go in just about any
deck and play well if you haven't used
bomb box I guarantee you will run into
it but basically what bomb box does is
it's going to set up this little box and
it's going to throw these bombs now if
you have someone a unit out going close
to your enemy the bombs will actually
travel so they don't just stay right
there where the bomb is they travel with
the unit and they're going to explode
and they do incredible incredible damage
so my deck is really built to do a lot
of damage using the bomb box so we've
got also the monster book here monster
book is great if you ever have somebody
that's using nebulous it only costs 3MP
so they use nebulous you can throw the
monster book it's going to go right in
and break that nebulous charm also it
will carry the bombs too so monster book
is great also good at taking out
nifflers also good at taking out another
bomb box actually so if somebody else
plays a bomb box throw a monster book at
it it'll start chomping at it very very
strong then you also have the Cornish
pixie so I just like having an aerial
unit I know some people prefer the
floopers but bloopers cost five whereas
these only cost three and also mine are
higher level than my flooper so uh we'll
see I might end up changing that at some
point but so far the Pixies have been
treating me well the cats are really
strong because they're just so annoying
the fact that they split whenever you
destroy one it it just it's constantly
something that somebody has to focus on
and like Pixies and like the monster
book They're going to carry the bombs as
well so all three of these right here
the monster book The Pixies and the cats
will all carry these bombs for me then
I'm actually going to skip ahead to my
biggest card here which is not even a
legendary but it's the stack of Monster
books now this one I have rotated in and
out at times and if I don't use this one
then I can usually take the niffler out
but I just love this card I really love
this card I feel like not a lot of
people play it and so whenever it gets
thrown a lot of times you can catch
people off guard now it's gonna be best
paired with the bomb box for sure if
somebody has an incendio ready speaking
of incendio I've got it right here it
will take out the Monster books almost
immediately so that is kind of one
downside of this card and anybody who if
you're looking to counter it just have
it incendio ready if you know somebody
has the stack of Monster books but
otherwise if you know they've just used
their incendio or you know that they're
in trouble you send these three Monster
books in and it's just so so
overwhelming if you have any of these
other three going in with the stack of
Monster books plus the bombs it's insane
damage now that's a lot of MP that's
hard to build up to but we'll take a
look at these matches here and you'll
see uh if we're able to get it or not
atmospheric charm if you've seen my
video about the Norwegian Ridgeback egg
atmosphere charm is essential for that
now right now it's it's currently banned
but I'm still keeping atmospheric charm
in my deck also because it's like one of
the few spells in the game that is
essentially unblockable I mean they can
go into nebulous but if you get them out
of nebulous this is going to follow them
around it's going to annoy you can put
it over companions that you want to get
rid of you can put it over like the egg
you can put it over unicorns you can put
it over all kinds of things and they
they can't get it to go away so
especially when you have something
that's stationary atmospheric charm is
really really good and remember I'm
playing as Bellatrix so I want to just
get as many hits as possible so
sometimes I'll even throw that to start
the match just to start immediately
getting hits on people and you know it's
it's just kind of annoying to start with
that and then somebody's like they have
to use nebulous they have to start
moving they don't want to use up their
movement cards and then we have niffler
I know there's a little bit of back and
forth right now on how valuable the
nifler actually is one of the underrated
aspects I will say of the niffler is the
fact that people feel like they have to
take it out and a lot of times it is you
know they do need to take it out so
they're gonna have to spend resources to
take out the niffler which can then in
turn open up some other things for you
so so basically the whole time I was
making my way to Diamond if I had
niffler at the start I would always play
it always play it at the start and then
move away from the niffler that's very
key you don't want to sit right by the
niffler because then they can get damage
on you and take out the niffler and then
for companions I like to start with Ivy
so many people are running Ron right now
that might change over time actually now
that I've played a lot of diamond
matches people are kind of getting smart
and not using Ron at the beginning but
throughout silver gold you're probably
going to see a lot of people running Ron
first and to be able to just instantly
take Ron out with Ivy now I will say the
thing about Ivy is it's very tricky
sometimes if you don't aim it just right
or if there's a little bit of lag issues
going on maybe your ping is too high ivy
can miss and she will actually Target
something different than what you
intended and this has burned me a couple
of times but more often than not more
often than not if you can line it up
just right and make sure you get it on
run or it could be a Cassandra it could
be another companion that you're trying
to get rid of then Ivy is great because
it just instantly takes them out and
then you have her on the field doing
battle for you and she will also carry
those bombs as well I like to put Ron in
the second slot because so many people
are running Ivy in one right now and the
way I play I usually don't use my
companions first I usually feel like
sometimes people panic and use their
companions now more recently Hermione is
a really powerful first companion people
are doing the thunderstorm so they'll
throw Hermione and then throw double
thunderstorms so nebulous is actually
becoming a little bit more important and
then I have Malfoy gang here at the end
but Ron I feel like is good as a second
companion because if you're ever for
getting overwhelmed and you got a bunch
of units around you or maybe they throw
Ron or they throw a different companion
like Cassandra for example or some of
these other companions if they're smart
they're going to put them in the back to
where they're harder to hit but Ron is
just I mean when they you got a lot of
ads on the field and if you can feel a
moment where you can sort of shift the
battle so maybe you built up a lot of MP
there's a lot of ads around you throw
down Ron especially if you're running
Bellatrix if you know you're about to
get the Death Eater or even better
multiple Death Eaters you throw down Ron
that's why I also like having him in
second is because I know I'll be closer
to getting two or three Death Eaters by
that point so you throw down Ron then
you throw all of your Pixies or whatever
you want to pair with the bomb box and
the Death Eater and then it's it's a
really strong push really strong push
and then Malfoy gang at the end I've
actually been using a lot more of Hagrid
lately in this slot so Malfoy gang is
good too though just because there's
like you know it's
three other units that are going to
carry the bombs for you especially if
you have bombs it's really good but
Hagrid is also pretty solid in that slot
as well all right so let's take a look
at some gameplay here and this was a
platinum match on the way to Diamond and
I will say I've already improved so much
since watching this right here
I've learned to sort of be a little bit
more patient so you watch I throw my
monster book right away and then I throw
the bombtastic bomb whenever I can get
both of them going at the beginning I
sometimes like to just throw it out
pretty quickly
in reality maybe I should wait and let
them make the first move so now they've
got Lottie out over there so I know I
need to take her out and I know I need
to take out
the uh oh I can't think of the name of
it right now the fly occamy yeah need to
take that one out too and then currently
the locomotives are banned but they were
not banned at this point clearly and so
they also have you see they they've got
the egg over there now so this is a very
dangerous situation I've got locomotor
in front of me I've got the egg over
there so I get atmospheric charm going
on it
and that locomotor they're just so
strong and the the egg actually does
hatch so he gets the Norwegian Ridgeback
on the field he's also running Neville
so he's he's healing everything right
now
this fight is currently not looking good
for me I send in the full stack of
monster book because I know it's gonna
get me my Death Eater and look look at
the Death Eater completely obliterates
both the Dragon
and the locomotor for me which was
absolutely huge at that point
just huge so sending in that stack of
Monster books into that nebulous cloud
was really helpful and I don't know why
he didn't
try and focus on taking that Death Eater
out I mean because that Death Eater just
took out another locomotor is that four
four locomotives and I put an incendio
to try and uh do some damage to that
unicorn but unicorn gets out I hear the
Norwegian Ridgeback
fire off the full stack of Monster books
I know they're gonna eat away at the egg
while I work on the Unicorn over here
and so then he starts trying to heal but
I get the atmospheric charm on it
and we're just we've just been putting
out so many hits so even though his
damage like I'm down in the fight
look at that what 500 or so more than
500 right now but now I've got two Death
Eaters
I've got the bomb boxes throwing I've
got the cats right in his face and then
he uses that was a very good
confringo right there he took out a lot
and then he gets desperate he has to use
Ivy to take out one of my Death Eaters
man and he just
I don't know I got he just was not
prioritizing the Death Eaters and so
then I already
look dude that fight changed let's I I
want to go back real quick that fight
changed so quickly I mean look at this
we're at what two 202
.02 right there and I'm down 500 watch
how quickly this fight changes I've got
two Death Eaters on the field he's got
the locomotives which again are really
strong but when you get those units
carrying the bombs for you plus the
Death Eaters
and again he just wasn't prioritizing
taking them out now I already have a
huge lead he gets desperate to use his
Ivy but look at that my mirrors already
filled again so I still have one Death
Eater on the field three more are
spawning in and it it's over it's just
over
so really interesting comeback right
there in that match which I think for
that person it was just a case of them
not prioritizing the Death Eaters enough
all right so here we go with another
match and you're gonna notice some
similarities here in how this one plays
out they are running a Hagrid deck so
kind of similar to Neville but less
focused on the healing aspect because
Hagrid's just gonna give them
stronger summons so they've got a slight
Advantage but this is pretty close in HP
right there so I get the niffler out and
they immediately go up and throw the
locomotives I've got the bombtastic bomb
and the Pixies which do a decent job on
the locomotives if they actually hit
them but yeah you can see they're not
even like focusing on them okay that one
up there in the top the Pixies did hit
for a little bit so I deal with the one
in front of me but but splitting them up
is huge I can't wait to see how they're
gonna Nerf those I mean they have to
Nerf those locomotives at some point I
get the cats going the cat takes Avada
Kedavra
shrinks down into a tiny little kitten
and again this is an example of where
I've already gotten so much better like
throwing out that buntastic bomb right
there that was pointless and I'm also
playing up close way too much there is
no need for that no need for me to throw
out the bombtastic bomb right there if I
don't really have anything to pair with
it because they're just gonna focus on
it then they get their Norwegian Ridge
back I do have an atmospheric charm
ready also send in the monster book
so hopefully the monster book and the
atmospheric charm will take it out but
they are trying to heal it even though I
don't have a bomb box I want to go ahead
and get those Pixies in there too
because if he's just gonna totally Focus
On Healing I at least want to get some
free damage on him and then we get the
Death Eater again again like I don't
understand why they're not prioritizing
them there there you go they're not that
hard to take out
but if you let one get close to you
and you're not prioritizing it it is
tough see now they're in a really bad
spot I mean we have a huge Advantage at
this point the locomotives are out on
the field but they're basically having
to deal with the cats in our monster
book and all those bombs that we had in
there
they tried to heal that that was a big
mistake right there they tried to heal
them but it was they were already too
far gone I throw the stack and they have
to burn a confringo
to take it out
and then we've got the Pixies with the
bombs and you can just see we're keeping
on the constant pressure I go ahead and
I threw out the cap first and then the
incendio
so hopefully when they move
they'll go right into it
right into the cat but he used Avada
Kedavra
so look at this I'm like sitting in a
very good spot I had a full MP I had a
Death Eater on the field I sent in the
stack and watch how fast my meter is
building right now look at that look how
fast that meter was building I mean even
though we ended up winning the fight
anyway
our meter was building so quickly we
were about to get another wave of Death
Eaters which would have put them in an
even tougher position so guys give this
deck a try let me know what you think
I've already made some tweaks and
changes to it myself as I'm trying to
make my way through diamond and all the
way to Grand Masters as a free to play
player we'll see how I can do it if you
want to see more magic waking content
make sure you subscribe and it looks
like YouTube thinks that this video
right here will be a good one for you to
check out next as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon